le 5 janvier 2022 le chef de l'état
emmanuel macron avait déclaré vouloir l'
emmerder les non vaccinés ces propos un
chacun des propos qui ont enflammé
l'hémicycle où les 5,4 millions qui
n'ont pas reçu leurs premières doses de
vaccin et pour tous ceux qui
n'effectueront pas leur rappel vous
l'avez donc compris la vie va devenir
beaucoup plus compliqué
mais outre le pass vaccinale qu'elles
peuvent donc être les moyens mis en
place pour pousser la population à la
vaccination sur bfm le maire de nice
christian estrosi a soumis l'idée de
s'attaquer directement au portefeuille
des non vaccinés ceux qui ne seraient
pas vaccinés ne devrait pas avoir droit
accès à l'assurance chômage une
proposition radicale inspirés de nos
amis québécois qui en plus de priver de
chômage ce qui ne se vaccinent ray pas
ont instauré une taxe de contribution
santé oui j'ai pris un quotient 13h
contre ces gens là si pas de ça n'est
pas rendue obligatoire officiellement
les mesures mises en place pour est
contrainte de plus en plus de français
la vaccination alors faut-il être plus
sévère avec les non vaccinés
merci alors du chômage confinement
faut-il être plus sévère avec les non
vaccinés merci merci ca beaumont
stéphane
on essaye tout le monde d'avoir su s'en
foutent ils s'en foutent ils sont comme
maître gims pierre gentil et avocats
merci bonsoir très bien oui oui on
trouve tous contents d'être là bas
j'étais pas de manigold vous êtes
d'accord et christian estrosi quand
c'est lui
cette information oui au départ j'étais
d'accord parce qu'en fait on est tous
excédé par une situation où l'économie
est totalement aujourd'hui paralysé mais
quand on prend du recul c'est ce que
j'ai essayé de faire ces mecs là en fait
ils cotisent les allocations chômage et
cotisent et donc ya pas de raison à ce
qu'on leur supprime en fait un droit
qu'ils ont donc quand christian estrosi
dit ça il rajoute ans et de l'huile sur
le feu et on nous tue en fait les vrais
sujets qui est la paralysie totale de la
france aujourd'hui nous on a une
désorganisation absolue je sais pas si
vous au niveau des seules six valeurs
techniques la c2 organisé ici non mais
ces gars je vois que le public est là
massivement donc a pas eu de cas
positifs mais nous c'est un cauchemar
quand on est en train de vivre donc
quand christian estrosi fait cette ses
positions au départ on peut dire oui il
a raison parce qu'en fait on en a marre
et on veut s'en sortir mais en fait il
fait juste que d'attiser le feu mais de
lui là où il y en a pas et là au moins
j'en veux c'est à des mecs comme fabrice
di vizio qui au fond toute la journée
prend des positions parce nazis terre et
compagnie j'en veux quelque part dabadie
déroule
mais met d'ailleurs je plaide christian
estrosi avait une position au départ pro
hydroxy chloroquine aujourd'hui il passe
de ça il faut condamner tout le monde
alors on va revoir la seleccion
christian estrosi qui propose à la fin
confinement strict et retirer les
allocations chômage attention didier
raoult et fabrice bios et des amis comme
vous avez des amis de partout au regard
des guillemets missir gamme et les amis
peuvent ne pas être d'accord pas
exactement c'est ça et diversité de ce
plateau d'invités bejo entre amis c'est
madame exactement
c'est les soldes aujourd'hui à bruxelles
favorable à l'obligation de la
vaccination vous êtes favorables à
l'obligation à ceux qui ne seraient pas
vaccinés 1 devraient être confinés chez
eux dans les mêmes conditions que nous
étions tous confinés au mois de mars et
au mois d'avril 2020 et par ailleurs ne
devrait pas avoir droit accès à
l'assurance chômage pas d'assurance
chômage absolument comme au canada comme
au canada pas d'assurance chômage pour
les non vaccinés non parce que quand on
fait prendre de tels risques à la
société eh bien on doit en payer le prix
alors pierre gentille avocat vous pensez
quoi des propositions de christian
estrosi moi je pense qu'ils doivent
aller plus loin on devrait mettre ce
genre prison non mais c'est idiot vous
avez été vous avez été outré entendant
ça non mais écoutez c'est ridicule déjà
faut rappeler une chose vous l'avez
rappelé christian estrosi il a changé
beaucoup de positions effectivement il
était pour l'hydro si chloroquine parce
qu'il sait que par chez lui a dit raul c
est assez populaire mais christian
estrosi c'est le maire de nice et nice
est un peu la capitale des boumeurs en
france donc évidemment il fait plaisir à
son électorat c'est logique ensuite si
on peut raisonner 30 secondes ce propos
il faut le poser dans le bon sens
faut-il être plus sévère avec les non
vaccinés mais vous savez endroit pour
être sévère pour infliger une sanction
il faut encore qu'il y ait une faute
alors quelle est la faute de ces gens-là
endroits il n'y a pas d'obligation
nationale donc s'il n'y a pas
d'obligation vaccinale il n'y a pas de
faute de ces gens-là dont dire qu'on va
leur retirer l'assurance chômage dire
comme j'ai entendu sur d'autres plateaux
on ne devrait pas leur faire payer à
leurs fins d'hôpital ouais juridiquement
c'est une connerie et moralement c'est
aussi une connerie donc mais j'ai envie
de dire avec christian estrosi c'est un
peu une suite je suis un peu sévère mais
christian estrosi non on ne verra pas
nice cet été non mais j'aime pas trop
sonné mais panis fait dans nos modestes
en dessous la loire je vais vraiment non
je rigole non non je rigole non mais
est-ce qu'on peut on peut aussi avoir
charmé être un peu de moralité pour nos
soignants 9 non mais quand tu es à 9 non
c'est pas neuf admission non mais non
les veuves ces messages et les chiffres
de la drees et ces chiffres ont été
démenties il n'ya pas neuf personnes sur
dix savoir et 10 non vaccinés ce chiffre
était démontée hier au sénat il y à 54 %
des gens en réanimation ces chiffres de
la drees à ses 54 % des gens en
réanimation qui n'ont aucune dose donc
46 % de gens après qu'ils ont soit de
dos soit qui en trois doses qui sont pas
georges mathieu tu sais tu vois on
discute et oui mais vraiment oui à mu
vraiment même voir donner parce qu'en
fait pas ce qui s'est passé bat
christian estrosi c'est la conséquence
de quoi on a tout fait par la manière
sauf pour essayer de les convaincre on
n'y arrive pas alors ça suffit
effectivement les gens qui remplissent
les réanimations les gens qui font en
sorte que aujourd'hui effectivement on
décale comme je lé vue à lyon avec une
d'heureux une neurologue qui décale des
cancers et des gens qui doivent être
véritablement soigner ça suffit les gens
leurs deux minutes vous allez reprendre
après mille fois d'accord et vous vous
posez je te poser une question oui non
messieurs font moi je suis là pour des
bottes donc je trouve qu'ils sont très
sérieuses ces gens occupent des places
en réanimation mais qu'ils coûtent cher
à la société effectivement il occupe une
majorité un même prix sans concurrence
et une majorité d'accord est-ce qu on
est d'accord que sur cette même logique
on pourrait dire que en cancérologie
cancérologie du poumon à des fumeurs on
leur dit écoutez c'est votre choix vous
avez pris un risque et ça pèse sur la
société donc vous allez payer mais ça
c'est bête monsieur
[Applaudissements]
je suis dans notre vision des problèmes
avec al rai la société n'a plus de
cohérence et moi je les gens ont le
droit de prendre un risque une société
risque zéro c'est une société
totalitaire il ya des gens qui fument ya
des gens qui vaudra vous êtes mis déjà
vous êtes m'étais déjà que donc les gens
qui sont non vaccinés comme les fumeurs
les jardins aurait une sont majoritaires
et frène enorment brice était erronée
pour la société mais les fumeurs sont à
risque pour lui je suis camerounais
prend
lorsqu'il la chute des places en
réanimation mais j'ai pas de prob avec
sa moralité payer j'ai pas de prendre
avec la moralité mais j'ai rencontré un
médecin qui est au bord l'urgentiste et
qui me dit stéphane qu'est ce que je
fais j'ai quelqu'un un nombre x
anti-vaccins 20 ans en réa j'ai
quelqu'un qui a 50 ans triplement
vacciner en rêve je dois sauver
quelqu'un je sauve qui celui qui a fait
le choix de ne pas actionner ou celui
qui à 50 ans qui fumait encore agité la
mort israël et connaît ses limites et
aujourd'hui soit le gouvernement ne
prenne la république si ses conseils
nous écoutent ils enlèvent la prothèse
en plastique qui sont greffe une vraie
et il dit la chose suivante nomi des
choses j'avais préparé six noms messine
c'est une simple grippe et on passe à
autre chose on laisse circuler le virus
par
vous ironisez et et mathieu avait un
argumentaire sérieux mais je suis en
total antagonistes les chômeurs c'est
pas un choix d'un calvaire d'être au
chômage pour eux pour ces gens là ils
ont perdu un travail et c'est la double
peine c'est à dire qu'on va stigmatiser
des chômeurs qui n'ont rien demandé ceux
qui sont déjà dans une situation
extrêmement délicate oh non
effectivement d'une politique sanitaires
extrêmement précaires telus dont on ne
sait pas grand chose de sûre la paix sur
les chômeurs c'est trop facile donc pour
moi c'est le chômeur il ne peut pas si
on en les plaçant les émissions décembre
assure gilles étapes même sur eux c'est
eux aussi de passer
je vous donne un exemple c'est quand le
chômage est un drame s'est doublée g
l'air de ne borde pas là-dessus gilles à
quel moment j'ai dit que le taux de
chômage s'était pas un drame jeudi que
la question la question c'est ça une
arrive à surfer mais faut-il leur
enlever leurs allocations non ce que je
vois tu fais toi tu penses tu veux être
plus sévère et que les non vaccinés à
d'enseignement absolument il faut être
plus sévère avec son non vaccinés encore
une fois ce gouvernement a fait un choix
il ira au bout il pense comme la grand
majorité des pays dans le monde que
c'est le second des cadets qui a germé
au canada
de se faire vacciner c'est le bon choix
pour ces derniers car le monde le
gouvernement a fait ce choix là ça
gouvernement qu'on l'a élu
démocratiquement maintenant il ya un
moment il faut aussi suivre et il faut
qu'on soit tous dans le même choix pour
qu'on vive en suscitant une pollution
par exemple oui j'ai un journaliste qui
est arrivé aujourd'hui dans ma société
on une vingtaine à peu près qui était
normal en journée comartin
mais voilà je les adore jouer engagé et
il m'a dit je suis non vaccinés les dix
neuf autres le sont et ils le sont parce
que je leur ai demandé de l'être pour ne
serait-ce qu être assez en sécurité
vis-à-vis des autres y en a qui sont
coachés plus gros plus faible puis
machin qu'est ce que je fais tout
journaliste je le prends donne un
mauvais exemple je le prends pas alors
que j'en fais ça vous avez droit le
prendre si vous voulez je dois le
prendre mais niveau de la morale qu'est
ce que je fais maintenant par rapport
aux 19 à vis des autres il ya un moment
et vis-à-vis des autres bien voilà
monsieur m'a voilà qu'est ce qu'on fait
monsieur khellout années connaissent et
a demandé aux autres de se vacciner
c'est pourquoi des connards mais c'est
pas moi qui ai déconné l'autorité s'est
pas excusé moi on peut juste raisonner à
l'endroit des je vais revenir ce que
vous avez dit la vaccination il faut le
dire c'est une arme utile pour éviter
les formes graves par personne ne le
conteste et bourdin williams atteint
mais c'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est
qu'on nous a vendu depuis quatre cinq
mois que la vaccination allait nous
sortir du calvaire de mesures
liberticides qui s'additionnent depuis
un an ça fait deux ans que ce cirque
continue nous avons 90 % cu à sion et
l'egypte qui est vaccinée nous avons
quatre cent mille cas nous n'avons
jamais eu autant de cas il est pourtant
nous avons 90 pour 100 kg qui vaquent
c'est enfin derrière chose le problème
en réanimation quand vous dites il faut
que tout le monde fasse vacciner il faut
que les 5 6 millions personnes vaccinées
moi je pense qu en fait chacun doit
faire sa balance bénéfices risques est
le vrai sujet ce n'est pas les 5 6
millions dans les cinq signaux il ya des
gens qui ont 20 30 40 50 ans qui ont
votre âge qui mon âge ils n'ont
quasiment aucune chance décès du co vie
de ces gens là moi je vais pas vous
balancer les chipotages d'enseignés pas
les chiffres mais les chiffres de
mortalité pour les jeunes c'est ridicule
je ne savais combien de morts de moins
de 40 ans de moins de 40 ans au mois de
décembre et quand on terrorise les gens
quand on tirait au regard des gens il
faut parler un peu des chiffres je sais
on a alors les gens sous les chiffres
c'est calme c'est bête monsieur que
quand on dit rapidement qu'à 53 min 30
sec et si on peut bloquer la mort et
qu'on les a sauvés et qu'il ya vingt
personnes jeunes
la vaccination va pas utile
mais ce n'est pas ce que je vous dis
encore une fois je vous dis pas que la
vaccination n'est pas utile je vous dis
simplement que doit être ciblée cette
pop et cette maladie elle touche une
partie population qui ne risque rien
donc il n'ya pas imposer des mesures
obligatoires pour cette population et
c'est l'oreille à l'enfant de la scène
dans la dernière et aujourd'hui on me
gratte
sakho va arriver l'argument du pathos
quand on n'a rien à dire monsieur en
l'occurrence est ce qu a dit romain
serman c'est toujours grave mais ce que
pour 1 mais on a répliqué impasse
vaccinale des restrictions aux libertés
dumas c'est un masque partout non je
vais vous dire une chose il y avait des
déprogrammations lors des précédentes
grippe ou et des hôpitaux qui saturaient
il y avait des grèves souvenez vous il y
avait des grèves des urgentistes est-ce
qu'on a fermé le pays pour autant est-ce
qu'on a imposé des masques pour autant
nous on ne l'a pas fait notre société a
changé
qui dit oui je dis oui la spirale
attention je dis oui à cette question
faut-il être plus sévère avec les non
vaccinés le chômage moi je dis qu'il
faut empêcher les neuf accusés
normalement pour les pousser la
vaccination quand vous voulez mais en
revanche il faut pas les empêcher de
vivre tout cas on l'espère chômage c'est
quand même merci donc pas les empêcher
de vous j'en ai versé moi je suis je
suis pour être plus cher parce que j'en
ai assez ça fait deux ans qu'on prend
des demi mesures moi j'étais en
tremblant fermé trois doses j'ai peur du
vaccin parce que j'entends tellement de
choses j'en ai peur mais je le fais
notamment pour ma mère je les fais j'ai
tout bien fait j'ai fait vous n'imaginez
pas le parcours du combattant parce que
ça on n'en parle jamais le parcours du
combattant pour faire vacciner est ce
que parce que c'est très dur une dame de
90 ans qui a levé le maire vous imaginer
comment on peut les vacciner je me suis
battu pendant des mois ce n'est pas
trouver une personne qui se déplace à
son domicile pour la faire vacciner sa
saison là ils font partie les
non-vaccinés aussi je n'ai fait vacciner
qu'en août alors que c'est la chose à
laquelle je tiens le plus parce que je
ne trouvais personne et qu'on ne peut
pas l'emmener elle va hurler elle va se
débattre c'était c'était horrible
c'était un moment sachez parcours du
combattant là il ya des gens
certainement alors peut-être tout
simplement ils sont isolés dans des
zones rurales il ya des gens qui
voudraient se faire vacciner qui ne
peuvent pas moi je pense que les
antilles vax et des problèmes de riches
je suis désolé si
accès aujourd'hui combien y aurait une
mort en plus sa vieille ville saint
sauvy des milliers de millions de monde
de mort pardon dans le monde entier
assure et donc il faudrait aussi parler
de ceux qui aimeraient se faire vacciner
ma mère j'ai trouvé enfin une infirmière
qui venait elle ne vient que le 1er
février je tremble parce que là on est
maintenant à laquelle je tremble pendant
dix ans il ya quatre ans on a des
raisons sur vaccinés oui à 30 40 50 ans
quand on aurait dit je le suivais la loi
peut-elle obligation vaccinale le débat
et si madame je respecte votre
souffrance et le débat ici c'est pas
l'efficacité du vaccin on n'est pas
scientifique je suis pas son nom mais
c'est pas là visibles est-ce qu'on va
imposer à toute une population
l'obligation de se faire vacciner sous
peine de sanctions alors qu'il ya des
gens qui sur la balance bénéfices
risques non pas se vacciner c'est ça le
sujet madame c'est parfait
vim
tameka et le risque de caries gros trous
mais non vous l'avez bien mérité
pour cette création qui est vaccinée
vous le voyez bien je suis le gars des
latrines sauter d'un vacciner c'est il
ya quand même beaucoup moins de chance
de redirections
évident